en el vídeo anterior les dije que íbamos
a calcular la velocidad final del
proyectil al momento de caer y bueno por
cuestiones de tiempo no lo pude terminar
en el vídeo pasado así que lo vamos a
resolver ahora veamos los componentes
horizontales y verticales del vector
velocidad final
el componente horizontal de la velocidad
es sencillo es este valor 30 cocinas de
80 grados ahora lo que necesitamos
conocer conocer es el componente
vertical de esta velocidad
en el vídeo anterior encontramos que el
valor del tiempo en el aire era 5 puntos
67 segundos y para encontrar el
componente vertical sabemos qué
todo esto es
con respecto a la componente vertical
vertical para que no nos confundamos el
cambio en la velocidad
vertical
es igual a la aceleración
multiplicada por el cambio en el tiempo
conocemos el cambio en el tiempo y
conocemos cuál es la aceleración
vertical que es la aceleración de la
gravedad y recordamos que como va hacia
abajo este vector va a ser una cantidad
negativa y es menos 9.8
a la velocidad este elemento el promedio
de la velocidad del cambio de la
velocidad pero en el cambio de la
velocidad es esta fórmula
es la velocidad final
menos la velocidad inicial
y esto va a ser igual a mi aceleración
que es negativa menos 9.8
am
metros sobre segundo al cuadrado por el
cambio en el tiempo que resultó de
5.67 segundos entonces este segundo se
cancela con uno de estos
conozco mi velocidad inicial que es la
que tengo aquí mi componente
este componente de la velocidad inicial
30 seno de 80 grados
lo que no sé es mi velocidad final eso
es lo que quiero encontrar entonces mi
velocidad final
- mi velocidad inicial que era 30
seno de 80 grados
es igual a 9 menos 9.8 por 25 puntos 76
9.8 por
5.67
- 55 punto 57
-
punto 57 metros sobre ese mundo
por lo que despejó lo que me interesa a
mi velocidad final es igual a
mejor cambio de color para no consumir
tanto 30
seno de 80 grados
- 55 puntos
así que hacemos esta operación
es
80 grados seno de 80 grados por 30
y esto es menos esto le restamos
55 punto 57
menos 26 puntos 0 25 lo dejamos en menos
26 puntos 0 2 mi velocidad final
-
26.02
metros sobre segundo qué significa esta
cantidad negativa a pues que el vector
velocidad va hacia abajo eso es lo que
significa nos está dando la dirección
así que
pues ahora sí vamos a
reconstruir nuestro
ya tenemos y ahora si podemos ahora sí
que reconstruir nuestros vectores
nuestro rector velocidad total tenemos
que nuestra componente horizontal
era el
30 coseno de 80 que venía siendo un
valor su magnitud 5.21 y su dirección
pues bueno es horizontal va hacia la
izquierda es cantidad positiva el vector
el componente horizontal es el que
acabamos de encontrar que es de menos
- 26
punto 02 va hacia abajo porque es una
cantidad negativa y ahora quiero
encontrar mi velocidad mi vector
velocidad total que va a ser la suma de
estos dos vectores entonces si lo pongo
desde donde inicia el primero hasta
donde termina el segundo disculpen
ustedes que no estos vectores no se me
vayan tan derechitos
este va a ser mi
vector velocidad total y también tengo
que encontrar el ángulo de la misma
manera que encontramos lo que
reconstruimos el vector
los vectores de desplazamiento lo vamos
a hacer aquí con este y voy a tratar de
escribir
así que más
con letra más chiquita para que me quepa
en este espacio
vamos a tener que la magnitud de mi
vector
velocidad
va a ser igual a por el teorema de
pitágoras
voy a hacer voy a irme aquí un poco más
rápido es la raíz cuadrada de el cateto
opuesto al cuadrado más el cateto
adyacente al cuadrado entonces
va a ser
5 puntos
21 al cuadrado más
como esta cantidad va a ser elevada al
cuadrado no importa que sea negativa se
va a volver positiva
26.02 al cuadrado y este valor va a ser
igual ya hice el cálculo para hacerlo
más rápido
26.55
metros sobre segundo esta es la magnitud
de este vector
velocidad
26.55 como lo voy a hacer la dirección
tengo que encontrar este ángulo que de
nuevo les llamo ángulo z
y este ángulo lo puede encontrar
de hecho pues porque vamos a usar la
tangente
quiero encontrar un ángulo tal que su
tales gente sea igual
26.02
/
se me pierde el color
el cateto el yacente 5.21 como puedo
encontrarlo con la función inversa de él
la tangente entonces este ángulo es
igual a la al arco tangente o la
tangente inversa de esta cantidad
26.02 /
5.21
y esta cantidad es igual a
78.7 grados hacia el sur o hacia abajo
de la horizontal o también lo podemos
describir como 70 menos 78.7 grados para
indicar que es un ángulo por debajo de
la horizontal